quand l'art urbain s'invite dans le
cursus scolaire des collégiens
c'est toute la beauté artistique de leur
travail qui est alors possible de
regarder ici au collège de beauséjour il
y avait un mur
la façade du gymnase principal de
l'époque qui passent chaque jour là
alors une idée dimanche en baladant donc
long du mur là donc j'ai vu qu'il y
avait pas mal d'affinités mons était
sale dans le sens propre comme au figuré
de me suis dit il faut faire quelque
chose
on va essayer de décorer les murs de
faire une fresque murale de façon à ce
que le mur soit respectée et surtout ça
on s'intègre bien dans le
environnement c'est alors que se met en
place un vrai projet avec des
partenaires dont notamment le conseil
départemental c'est a eu lieu une
structure qui accueille des personnes en
situation de handicap la page et voilà
que deux noms se rencontrent c'est la
rencontre la rencontre les jeunes et le
monde des personnes en situation
d'handicap une vraie rencontre hui le
niveau d'incompréhension pas été
renversés planant peuvent à des rapports
vraiment
sincère sans a priori
l'apache fait beaucoup de des changes
avec des collèges que ce soit pour
défendre les pour des activités comme
celle ci pour la fresque et ça permet
aux jeunes de voir le handicap
différemment je l'aimé mais de
travailler avec que la page parce que je
les ai connus dans un temps avec le
pollen juin et ben c'est sûr qu'avec un
travail complet débute dans la classe
avec des croquis et surtout des
propositions des élèves qui se confronte
à celles de l'artiste ont signé le graff
qui va habiller cet espace sa libre
expression prend alors tout son sens on
a eu 43 m de murs à peindre tous
ensemble c'est ça fait 100 litres de
peinture ans qu'on a opposé ce moment là
c'était pas évident puisque départ
c'était deux groupes qui avaient pas
forcément l'habitude de travailler
ensemble et puis les jeunes ils n'ont
pas forcément eu l'occasion de toucher
une bombe
donc il ya un petit moment comme ça on a
dû se familiariser tous ensemble choisir
les dessins pour aller les reporter sur
le mieux après réalisée dans la foulée
et ça s'est vraiment bien passé se sont
investis et aujourd'hui mon est fier on
est tous fiers du résultat montre ils
ont pris les exemples seul mur y'a pas
le mur avec tout le monde c'est chouette
de se retrouver tu te diras tu es le
premier cours mais après quand je sais
j'ai commencé à venir ben ça m'a inspiré
donc je suis venu dans les séances tout
naturellement désigné le professeur
d'arts plastiques qui voit là un vrai
défi c'est pour l'occasion d'être
vraiment dans une phase de réalisation
qui dure assez longtemps avec une
réflexion en amont un travail sur sur la
durée c'est ça l'idée c'est de
travailler autrement qu'en classe et en
plus ça a été le cas de mes moyens de
rencontrer des gens en situation de
handicap avec les élèves se sont vos
coûts liés je pense que ça c'est riche
aussi bien humainement que niveau
pédagogique
les collégiens travers ce projet se sont
appropriés leur collège mais c'est aussi
un partage avec les gens du quartier qui
a permis de communiquer le respect de
l'espace public à chacun désormais de se
poser de regarder d'interpréter cette
fresque qui invite au vagabondage de
l'esprit